who is the best league of legends player
in the world today is it smeb the
resurgent veteran or faker the two-time
world champion the debate continues in
the World Championship semi-finals when
the Rox Tigers face SK Telecom t1 smeb
was a big part of the Tigers run to the
world finals in 2015 but he really hit
his stride after the Tigers added peanut
to the lineup with his new jungler by
his side
smeb took home MVP honors for both the
spring and summer splits the Tigers love
putting smeb at the center of their game
plans peanut provides plenty of ganks
and smeb pays back the investment with
great team fighting and big damage
output compared to his phenomenal
domestic play smeb's world championships
have been a bit of a letdown in the
group stage he made several simple
mistakes but he also found ways to
redeem himself in the quarterfinals the
Tigers gave smeb more early help and he
looks more comfortable to take down SKT
the Tigers will need to continue setting
smeb up for success faker is the most
celebrated law Pro of all time but this
year inconsistent play from his jungler
and top laner have made his job more
difficult
fakers still led SKT to a sprint
championship and won the midseason
Invitational so far at Worlds faker has
been making plays in and out of lane and
averaging more than four kills per game
but fakers true value comes from how his
simple presence forces enemy teams to
adjust their game plans
faker attracts ganks like flies to honey
and he's always the first target in a
teamfight that inflates his death count
but he rarely goes down easily which
buys time and space for his teammates to
avenge him with faker clearing the path
bang can assert himself as an
overwhelming damage threat together
through the world's best carry due out
and faker is the driving force
if smeb can lead the Rox Tigers to
finally overcome their rivals this week
he may truly become the undisputed best
player in the world but based on what
we've seen at this tournament faker
isn't ready to relinquish the title
you